je suis un peu enfin j'ai dérangé
toujours c'est pas idéal tu vois c'est
pas parce que tu as waouh
dans tous les cas je voulais dire c'est
vraiment cool de passer du temps avec
toi ouais je conforte je trouve que ça
se passe super bien entre nous
d'ailleurs si si tu veux passer à la
maison
alors ouais enfin si tu veux il n'y a
pas deux mais bien sûr on écoute on
s'entend vraiment bien tous les deux
alors je pense que je pourrais être
honnête bien sûr voici je voudrais pas
de gêne et tu rigoles t'inquiète sa fin
dis moi j'ai deux bits
voilà ça va ça va quoi je comprendrais
que tu sois choqué partie du mythe
oui non mais ça va on en 2016 je suis
vraiment pas quelqu'un de fermé d'esprit
non non c'est à 2 beat c'est génial ça
reste une malformation quand même oui
bien sûr bien sûr et je te trouve hyper
courage parce qu'en plus j'imagine que
l'état fait pas grand chose pour les
champs comme vous donc
alors les gens comme moi se déroule très
bien maintenant c'est sûr qu'il ya une
vraie discrimination à l'embauché
personne ne parle de nous dans les
médias les urinoirs sont super mal foutu
aulas et par dont j'étais en train de
réfléchir à quel point je trouvais ça
cool en fait que tu me fasses assez
confiance pour me dire que carrément tas
de deux bits quoi c'est normal et du
coup je peux te poser une question oui
est-ce que tu pardon pour l'expression
bande avec les deux oui ok deux fois
plus de plaisir
non parce qu'en l'occurrence j'ai deux
très petit pénis d'accord celle de
gauche et circoncise et celle de droite
devient bleue quand l'été arrive
condition qu'ils fassent 20 degrés pour
ça que je passe l'été en bretagne
voilà comme ça tu sais tout oui je n'en
voulais pas forcément tout savoir mais
c'est ok donc on peut changer de sujet
bien sûr juin
du coup tu es un peu parti cet été au
ouais mais j'ai mes parents on y va non
ok et à combien de testicules de cours
16 [ __ ] ya les noms mais pardon je
m'en fous que t2 beats escrocs ou je
sais pas quoi c'est pas moi ça me gêne
pas excusez moi monsieur oui j'avais
entendu que vous souffriez d'un sérieux
handicap
la maison tiens donc à vous offrir votre
pain pour saluer votre courage mais
reste revient à temps mais c'est pas la
taille ni lé nom n'est la couleur il ya
un porte moi je suis pas gêné je te jure
c'est moi du sujet les colas lui en
sucres très bien moi j'ai vraiment
vraiment pas chat en fait ces jeunes
châtain ben j'en possède une j'ai pas de
commande de chant soit
et vous faites souvent de quoi attendre
vous attendez souvent personne